اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من تل ابيب اهلا بكم
محكمه العدل الدوليه تطالب اسرائيل باتخاذ
جميع الاجراءات لمنع الاباده الجماعيه في
قطاع غزه وتطلب منها رفع تقرير للمحكمه
بشان هذه الاجراءات خلال الشهر وتقول ان
الحكم يفرض التزامات قانونيه دوليه على
اسرائيل وان عليها ضمان توفير الاحتياجات
الانسانيه الملحه في القطاع بشكل فوري
اكثر من 180 شهيدا في مناطق متفرقه من
القطع الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني قال ان
الاحتلال استهدف محيط مستشفى الامل ومجمع
ناصر الطبي في خانيونس جنوبي القطاع في
حين قالت الاونر ان شوارع غزه المقتضى
تشهد انتشارا مقلقا وقاتلا للامراض وسوء
التغذيه الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل ضابط
برتبه رائد من لواء جفعاتي واصابه 38
عسكريا في الساعات ال 24 الماضي
وكتائب القسام تقول انها استهدفت قوتين
اسرائيليتين غرب خان يونس وفي مدينه غزه
واوقعت افرادها بين قتيل وجريح وفي الضفه
الغربيه قوات الاحتلال تقتحم مخيمي قلنديا
وشعفاط للاجئين شمال مدينه القدس المحتله
وتشن حمله اعتقالات كما اندلعت اشتباكات
بين مقاومين فلسطينيين والاحتلال خلال
اقتحامه مدينه طوباس الى اللقاء
no